If you happened
to hear your angry uncle
banging his head
against a shed earlier,
it's because tonight at the DNC,
Hillary Clinton
officially accepted
her historic nomination
for president.
Jack, roll the clip!
-♪
-(laughter)
(cheers and applause)
Prepare
for Game of Thron pun.
I can't believe she still
hasn't gotten in trouble
for Bran-ghazi!
-Oh. You guys.
-(audience groaning)
I know. So long ago.
And to add insult to injury for
the GOP, she ended her speech
by pouring wine
on Carly Fiorina's face.
But, hey, Bernie Sanders seems
to be taking it well.
(laughter)
(applause)
When he hit the ground,
he actually shattered
into a pile
of Werther's Originals. Uh...
(laughter)
Comedians, now that Hillary has
claimed the Dems' throne,
what's a good slogan
for Hillary
of House Clinton,
first of her name?
Mike Birbiglia, go.
Uh, it'd be, like,
a bumper sticker.
It says, like,
"Hillary Clinton.
You guys remember
when Obama hugged me?"
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Yup.
Yup.
(applause)
Gillian Jacobs, who is
struggling with her voice.
Hillary--
literally, the only option.
(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-HARDWICK: Your voice is good!
BIRBIGLIA:
It is good.
She couldn't talk
before the show.
BIRBIGLIA:
Earlier today,
she couldn't talk,
and then I realized,
-she just doesn't want
to talk to me. -(laughter)
That's so weird. Everyone I meet
doesn't have a voice.
-I don't understand.
-(laughter)
Tami?
Hillary--
breaking glass ceilings
since before Trump's third wife
was born.
-HARDWICK: Yes, perfect!
-BIRBIGLIA: Oh.